Hello.
I'm Jonathan Simon with the
Google Cloud Platform team.
I'm going to talk to you about
Google Cloud Storage, and how
you can use JavaScript to
start building on top of
Google's powerful storage
infrastructure.
Cloud Storage is a fast,
scalable, and reliable storage
service offered by Google as
part of its Cloud platform.
For more details about Cloud
Storage, here are two links to
help you get started.
I'm going to show you a demo
of a Cloud Storage sample
application that uses the
JavaScript client library for
Google APIs.
The Google JavaScript client
library provides access from
the JavaScript environment to
Cloud Storage and many other
Google APIs.
Just add the script tag you
see here to your HTML to
include the Google JavaScript
API client library.
Now that you know how to include
the JavaScript client
library in your HTML, the next
thing to do is to grab the
code for the Cloud Storage
JavaScript sample application.
Since the source control for the
samples code is using Git,
the checkout command is git
clone, and then the name of
the GitHub repository.
The next thing you want to do is
navigate into the directory
containing the JavaScript
sample code.
Just copy and paste that CD
command into your terminal.
Then you'll want to follow
through the README, and enter
the details in the
index.html file.
That will include your Google
Cloud Storage project ID, your
client ID, and your API key.
After that, you can load
it up on a web server
and see it in action.
A quick way to start a simple
web server to view the demo is
by using Python's
built-in server.
So let's switch over
to a terminal
window and try it out.
You can see that I'm in the
Storage Getting Started
JavaScript directory.
And if we list the files
there, you can see the
index.html file, which I've
already updated to include my
applications details.
To start serving index.html
from a web server, we can
simply type Python -m
simpleHTTPserver.
There, now the Python web
server is running.
Notice that the default port
that it is serving
pages from is 8,000.
So we can open up our
browser and enter
http://localhost:8000
to load the sample.
Here's the cloud storage sample
application using the
JavaScript client library.
If this is your first time
signing in, you'll see an
Authorize button in the top-left
corner of the screen.
And when you click that button,
it will request
permission to access your
cloud storage resources.
When you click Accept and
complete the authorization
process, you can try out
a sample API call.
Let's start by listing all the
buckets that are currently
available for my project
in cloud storage.
So this sample application
returns a few pieces of
information, including an
explanation of the selected
API request, a bit of code
that's generated for the
request, and the API's
response to
the request we made.
So if we look at the
explanation, we can see that
we're querying the Google Cloud
Storage API for a list
of buckets and returning
that list.
Looking at the code, you can
see how we construct our
parameter object and initialize
a single parameter
to that which is then
passed to the Google
Cloud Storage API.
Looking at the API response,
which is formatted in JSON, we
can see we're getting back
a list of buckets.
But we don't currently have any
buckets in there, so let's
go ahead and insert a bucket.
Here's a bit of information
about the request.
Here's the JavaScript code that
you can copy and paste
directly into your code.
Notice that we specified
code-sample-test-bucket as the
ID of the bucket to
be inserted, and
here's the API's response.
Now let's go back to List
Buckets to make sure that we
actually inserted that bucket.
And indeed, we can see
that our items
array now has one bucket.
And the ID of that bucket is
code-sample-test-bucket.
Excellent.
We could do more than just
list and insert buckets.
We can also list a bucket's
access control list.
We can list and insert
objects, and more.
This sample is showing a subset
of all the API commands
available to help you understand
the look and feel
of making a JavaScript
request to the Google
Cloud Storage API.
Check out the cloud storage
documentation for the full
list of commands.
Now why don't we take a look at
the codes so we can really
understand what the request
looks like in JavaScript.
So if we open up index.html
in an editor and look up a
function like listBuckets,
that's all there is to it.
You can see we put together
a request.
And we pass in the project ID
for the project that we'd like
to list buckets for, and then
we execute the request.
Looking at the executeRequest
function, you can see it
accepts two arguments-- a
request object, and the name
of the API request being made.
Stepping into the function,
first we execute the request.
And then using a JavaScript
function literal, we output
the response to the HTML page
which you can see by jumping
down into the function.
We create HTML pre-elements,
and then we output the
response to the inner HTML
of that pre-element using
JSON.stringify.
And then finally, we append
that pre-element to a div
element that's visible
on the HTML page.
Let's review the workflow
for using the
JavaScript client library.
The first thing you'll
do is include the
Google JavaScript APIs.
Just script that source.
Then you can include or load the
Google API of your choice.
Here we're including the
Cloud Storage API.
And finally, you can make
requests and display responses.
It's as easy as that.
To wrap up, here are a few more
resources where you can
go to learn more.
If you have any questions or
feedback, please feel free to
reach out to us on Stack
Overflow or via email.
Thank you for watching.
Now that you've seen how easy it
is to get started, go ahead
and try out the Cloud Storage
JavaScript sample for yourself.